the front pages starting with the Metro
which mocks Boris Johnson's claim that
he misled Parliament over partygate
without meaning to do so their headline
they weren't proper Whoppers
but the star is even more blunt in their
assessment I'm not a liar I'm just a
Mr Johnson would of course refute
both those allegations the eye describes
him as fighting to save his political
career
the former prime minister's political
survival is also the main concern for
tomorrow's Guardian
while The Mirror Has a list of Boris
party gate excuses
but the male is in his Corner saying
bullish Boris up for the fights
here's Wednesday's Daily Telegraph
disclosing details of special
arrangements made by KIA storm and the
headline hypocrite starmer to avoid tax
on pension
the Ft hears that plans to raise the
state pension age 268 have been delayed
partly because of falling life
expectancy but also because conservative
MPS are believed to be worried about
angering middle-aged voters
foreign
don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you see on screen during the
program and that you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us discussing them and we are
joined by Sonia soda and Mark Wallace
good to see you both welcome back Sonia
nice to have you with us so it's going
to be a very busy day tomorrow Boris
Johnson's at fight for survival uh the
guardian saying that uh that is exactly
what he is doing what do you think we
can expect Sonia tomorrow
what I think Johnson is going to get a
very significant grilling from the
Privileges committee we've already seen
the evidence that the Privileges
committee has amass it's a cross-party
committee of MPS and they've said in
their report that they published a
couple of weeks ago ahead of Johnson
giving evidence to them that they
thought that it was you know very likely
that Boris Johnson and his advisors had
knowingly uh well rather Boris Johnson
had knowingly misled Parliament today
what we saw happen was Boris Johnson
released his own defense against some of
that evidence that was presented by the
Privileges committee but I think there
is still a number of outstanding
questions I think we can expect to see
quite a tough grilling from this
cross-party Committee of MPS for Johnson
tomorrow I think some of the questions
they're going to want to know the
answers to are you know how how can you
say that as prime minister as the person
who signed off these rules who
communicated them to the public Blick
that you just didn't understand them and
you didn't realize that socializing at
work with alcohol and secret santa
presents didn't break the rules
um so I think that's a key question I
think another question is why didn't he
correct the record if indeed he didn't
realize that he'd misled Parliament why
didn't he correct the record much much
sooner as ministers and former ministers
and MPS are supposed to do and then why
was he referring to one of the
Gatherings as a party in private
correspondence in one of his advisors if
he thinks if he genuinely thought it
didn't break the rules well Mark Boris
Johnson has put out a pretty strong
statement this evening and in summary it
would appear that tomorrow his defense
is going to be look yes I misled
Parliament but not knowingly and I
apologize that the earliest opportunity
um I think that's going to be part of
his defense we've obviously seen pages
and pages and pages in his um uh
submission that's been put forward
interestingly I think you see some uh
foreshadowing there there may be a bit
of settling of scores and a few side
swipes coming out from uh Boris as well
in terms of some of that evidence where
he has a he puts the boot in on his
former adviser Dominic Cummings is
barely credible in his view given their
kind of personal political differences
um and this is going to be a very
lengthy session it's going to be
um asunder says the committee are going
to be understandably out to demonstrate
on this you're such an important
prominent stage on such an important uh
prominent topic again such an important
prominent figure we can be able to
demonstrate that they're not giving
anyone an easy ride and he himself of
course um whatever you might think of
him is incredibly accomplished
um public performer under the in in in
under the kind of heat of the lights as
it were so I think we're going to see
um an awful lot of poppy coin harshly
and at times Bentley contested back and
forth from from both sides I'm not
entirely convinced a huge number of
people around the country are going to
change their minds tomorrow from what
whatever they might think tonight about
Boris Johnson or about this topic but to
a certain extent that isn't the point
yes on the other front of the eye has
quite an intriguing headline doesn't it
D-Day for Johnson xpm drags sunac into
the inquiry
well yes yes absolutely so this isn't
just a political problem for Boris
Johnson although obviously it is most
acutely an issue for him because of some
of the sanctions that the Privileges
committee might recommend to the House
of Commons but it's also a big issue for
Rishi sunak who was Boris Johnson's
Chancellor raises all sorts of awkward
questions about how sunak is going to
deal with this in the Commons because
this committee the Privileges committee
it's a cross-party committee as I said
it will produce findings about whether
Boris Johnson uh knowingly misled the
House of Commons and it can make
recommendations uh for the sanction that
he might face as a result and that could
be anything from you know asking him to
write a letter of apology to the House
of Commons to being suspended from the
House of Commons for a number of days
and of course if it's more than 10 days
that can lead to
um
it can lead to a recall petition which
if successful could actually even
trigger a by-election if enough voters
in Boris Johnson is constituency sign
that so that raises a question for Rishi
sunak which is if if the Privileges
committee recommend a sanction how
should Michigan handle that
parliamentary vote
um it sounds like what's going to happen
is there will be a free vote um
unquestionably there will be some
conservative MPS who who would probably
back Boris Johnson but that does create
a political problem for sunac and it's
sort of reawakens
um the issue it reawakens public anger
about the fact that the former prime
minister was found to have broken
covered regulations at a time when many
people were making sacrifices
um so it's not it's not great for the
current prime minister either in front
of the Daily Mail uh bullish Boris up
for the fight perhaps
are not unexpected headline mark But as
Sonia was saying
you know Party politics do play a role
in in all of this don't they Boris
Johnson has talked about the highly
parties and tone and content of the
interim report for example and does he
have a point
well I think there there are some
reasons to raise to an eyebrow from
time to time about the the conduct of
some parts of this inquiry it's quite
interesting that what's being tested
tomorrow is now whether he knowingly or
recklessly misled Parliament and that
there is a reasonable argument
um you know I happen to think that
personally happened to think that these
parties were obviously wrong when the
government is setting rules for everyone
else that have such a huge cost on on
citizens it should be going above and
beyond to a by its own rules but it does
concern me a little bit the idea of
recklessly misleading perhaps being
um introduced to this process however
Boris Johnson is going to he's going to
be really hoping that people will watch
this tomorrow thinking of the daily
mails headline the biggest risk fan for
all the tens of thousands of words in
tomorrow's newspapers is that people end
up thinking of the daily Stars headline
the idea that you end up no politician
should want to end up in a position
where the defense is basically I
couldn't get my head around it I was I
was being dim or I didn't understand it
particularly when they're your own rules
and you see this quite often where
politicians try and you remember when
Jeremy corbyn used to say things like
you didn't know that the person you'd
met was a baddie in one sort or another
whether you've been laying a wreath that
that you hadn't realized the
consequences of what he was doing when
your excuses basically a lack of
knowledge or some some kind of dim era
particularly or when it's rules that you
expect everyone else to abide by that
you've introduced that that in itself is
quite a damaging thing and that's
precisely what his critics would hope to
to level at him uh yeah just having a
look at that Daily Star headline
Pinocchio I'm not a liar I'm just a
the Metro goes with part again
inquiry Boris they weren't proper
Whoppers um Sonia he also says the
burden of proof should be higher does he
have a does he have a point there in
terms of how this whole process is being
carried out
I mean I don't think so
actually if you
lose when it comes to work
if somebody comes forward with an
allegation about you in the workplace
things like bullying harassment
discrimination discrimination within a
workplace context
often the the test is balance of
probability it's not the same test or
threshold for evidence that you would
find in a criminal court
um so I'm afraid this does rather smack
of Boris Johnson desperately clutching
at straws here relying on extremely
technical uh legalistic arguments uh I
actually think that that Daily Star
headline captures it very well I mean
his defense is basically well you know I
know I made these thoughts but you
couldn't expect me to interpret them
properly even though I expected every
other person in the country to do so
um and you know no there's no evidence
that an advisor told me that I was
breaking the rules I mean as if that
would wash for any other member of the
public some of whom have been finding
huge amounts of breaking covert
regulations and you know you're talking
about some young people who attended
parties who've been you know we've been
you know who faced really really
significant finds so um I I really don't
I don't think it washes and I think it's
actually a sign of desperation
personally I think Boris Johnson would
it wouldn't have been a very Boris
Johnson thing to do but would have been
a lot better just to say look I got this
wrong I made a mistake I'm really sorry
um that's key not what he's doing he's
clutching at every store
um available to him and I don't think
it's gonna do much for him in terms of
his public reputation amongst members of
the public who are still angry about the
fact that when they were making
sacrifices during the pandemic he seemed
to think it was okay for there to be
Gatherings with alcohol and secret santa
presents and birthday cake at Downing
Street
okay we shall find out more tomorrow
shall we um live on Sky News uh from two
o'clock
um let's move on to the Metro uh shall
we and the Fallout from the review Mark
into the Met police what did you make of
it and what did you make of the
commissioner rowley's response
foreign
in various ways I think quite a lot of
members of the public and unfortunately
based on some of the evidence we've now
seen a decent proportion of police
officers themselves will have been
um perhaps uh shocked but not surprised
is is the best way of describing it some
of these things which have been which
have come out I remember a previous
edition of this program where we were
talking about some of the um the one
things I seem to ever mentioning was the
acid test of whether police forces are
really serious about dealing with these
issues is going is whether they are
willing to subject themselves to what's
going on sorry to say to be a a string
of new exposes of long-standing scandals
and issues not just in the match but in
other forces
um I suspect this is another this is one
episode but it's far from the end of
this and unfortunately part of the
difficulty I think is you know it's
important to have the um you know the
senior police officers themselves
knowledge the seriousness of of these
findings it is a bit comfortable it is
about unfortunate I think that in London
where we have a police and crime
commission who is the mayor of London
um I think it's a bit unfortunate that
there seems to be some attempt by City
Hall to separate itself from the
administration of the police I mean this
is a man who's been in place for quite a
long time and doesn't seem to have
properly uh it seems to now be saying
well I'm shocked to find out what
happens inside the police when he's
meant to be the person who does you know
the electorates oversight on our behalf
Sonia baroness Casey believes that the
rot spreads Beyond London she believes
that all forces need to conduct a a
proper uh review in into what goes on uh
amongst their offices and staff and as
our home editor Jason Farrell is
highlighted tonight um you know examples
in humbicide
um police um this is going to go on and
on isn't it
it is and I think it's really striking
that back in 1999 the McPherson inquiry
set out it's finding that the Met police
or institutionary basis had he used
quite a clear definition of what
institutional racism means and then you
know 25 to 30 years it was almost 30
years later
um you know we we find that not only of
issues not really good but better but
actually on some measures for example
the disproportionate used to stop and
search against black people here the
metrics have actually got worse and I
think it really underlines the fact that
you've had a lot of warm words from
people running them at
um about how you know they they're going
to get a grip of this culture they're
going to reform uh but that's it that
just doesn't seem to have happened and I
think the findings that Louise Casey
makes not just in terms of institutional
racism be institutional misogyny and
homophobia they speak to very
deep-seated cultural issues that it's
going to be very difficult
um to reform but it absolutely needs to
happen and I think any reform with the
police has to Grapple with the fact that
actually if you become a police officer
you get lots of power over people now
there's lots of very well-meaning people
who want to do that job for exactly the
right reasons but it also attracts some
quite unsavory types and so there are
really big questions about a how you
filter those people out and stop them
from getting into the police in the
first place but also what you do about
them when they're in the police force
and you know we've got police officers
like Wayne cousins serving police
officers who committed the most heinous
crimes and the the Met police missed
multiple occasions in order to you know
which would have helped them pick that
up and to get rid of that police officer
um you know and clean the fact that he
committed other crimes so um you know
this is such a serious issue
um and um you know I don't know about
others but I given how long we've you
know how many Revelations have been
about them in recent years it leaves you
feeling quite pessimistic in some ways
about the prospect for reform uh Mark
let's turn our attention
we to
Russia and China I quite like this
headline inside the Metro hello my old
China Vlad ready for Chi
um how would you sum up what happened
today
well there's a strong element of judging
a man by the company he keeps and I
think you can see here uh the leaders
who have won dictatorship who stands
internationally accused of a genocide
against the weaker people uh meeting the
lead of another dictatorship who is uh
just being charged at the international
criminal court with uh cognitive
aggression and uh and is also visibly
guilty of a genocide against the
Ukrainian people and what's interesting
here is quite how much the world has
changed since the the there used to be a
Russia China and sometimes fraught uh
access
um effectively during the Cold War in
which China was often
um seen to be the weaker partner times
have changed in a big way and Vladimir
Putin has accelerated that by his
foolishness and his incompetence he's
put himself really whether you wouldn't
like to admit it but at the mercy of uh
Xi Jinping and the Chinese regime now in
terms of the economic support the money
they're seeking the weapons that we I'm
sure would have been discussed off
camera and particularly things artillery
child supplies and so on
um this is very troubling and we need we
need to watch this we need to remember
that one detect ship wherever they are
in the world will always find comfort in
the existence of more dictatorships
because a world of free states in which
there's only one dictatorship left would
not be a happy one for whichever
dictator that was yeah um and Sonia NATO
warning China today about giving Russia
arms um well Putin also is issuing a
warning to to Britain about these uh
depleted uranium shells
that's that's and I mean I agree with
sort of a lot of what Marx just said
there which is that um you know these
are two men who are both incredibly
authoritarian uh based on accused of
awful human rights abuses
um and you know they they're two
countries that appear to be um drawing
closer so
um it yes it definitely poses as a
threat I think to um NATO to the US and
to Western alliances and Mark very
quickly just tell us about this story on
the front of the financial times with
regard to the state pension age
yes well this this is the long expected
some would argue in the economic terms
long overdue uh raising of the state
pension age on the basis the population
is getting uh older there's some
suggestions going to be delayed because
of the faltering rise in slowing or
faltering rise in life expectancy of
course politically for the conservatives
it could be a pretty contentious thing
to do raising the pension age just for a
general election when your vote is let's
be honest uh on the the older side of
the population
uh yeah Tory MP's fear uh a voting
backlash is what the Ft says um very
quick thought Sonia on this from you
well I think what's interesting
story says that when the the age
increase was planned to 68.
um you know people thought that life
expectancy was going to continue to
increase and actually that hasn't
happened so it's not where life
expectancy isn't where you might have
expected it to be on retirement
um when these changes were planned in
I think over time we definitely do need
an increase in the pension at state
pension age given that we're all living
longer
um but I think this raises questions
about how quickly it should be done also
there are huge social inequality
um questions here so life expectancy
varies very very significantly depending
on what kind of job you did
um what levels of deprivation you live
with
um you know during your working life so
I I think there are some important
questions
we're out of time